five weeks ago general abdul sata
mursakwal stepped into the role of
afghanistan's interior minister in all
he commands a force of 130 000 people
today he is driving to wardak a province
west of kabul much of the province is
controlled by the taliban for government
personnel traveling by road is rare and
requires an escort of special forces
in the last three months the taliban has
more than doubled its territory and in
the last week started to take provincial
capitals
what's going through your head at the
moment about those provinces how how
worried are you
and and how do you stop more falling
we are working in three phases the first
is to stop the defeats the second is to
re-gather our forces to create security
rings around the cities
all those soldiers that abandoned their
post were bringing them back to their
posts the third is to begin offensive
operations
these trips are about boosting morale he
admits that has suffered with the
advances the taliban has made after the
taliban attempted to assassinate the
defense minister and promise to target
other government leaders security around
minister mirzaquel has never been
tighter a simple task of visiting
checkpoints requires this many special
forces
he has survived multiple taliban
assassination attempts in his previous
jobs as the governor of kunar and kunduz
i'm a soldier a soldier never gets
frightened
when we wear this uniform it means we
are ready for death i'm not worried
about it
he says a lot of the government's losses
are as a result of them losing control
of roads and highways many areas must be
resupplied by air and after the u.s
withdrew they lost a lot of that
capability
unfortunately with their withdrawal the
fighting started in 400 areas of the
country
we have very limited air support the
helicopters have been busy with moving
supplies and evacuating our dead and
injured forces
so they are delegating to local leaders
empowering them to recruit within their
community to rise against the taliban
there are concerns from the
international community about these
uprising forces at the moment
but all their members will eventually
merge into the afghan national security
forces
wardak's governor says he already has
300 men fighting in one force but he
complained he could only provide weapons
for two-thirds the rest he said he
cannot provide with water let alone
money or arms
for the last few months people are
waiting for their weapons but
unfortunately the promises i made to
these people were not fulfilled but
there is no doubt in their loyalty and
desire to help
outside the room the minister's men wait
wardak police and soldiers join them
this talk of last night's gains and
losses where they may be sent next and
how their many injuries are healing some
briefly leave to push off a taliban
assault
[Music]
thousands of police officers have
abandoned their posts some recent months
the interior ministry says they are
returning and will be retrained then
sent back to the provinces
they say 5 000 people have signed up for
the police force in just the last three
weeks with another two thousand
graduating this weekend
the government strategy is slowly
becoming clear but its implementation is
still fraught and the stakes have never
been higher
if the taliban are watching what would
you say to them
i'm asking the taliban to stop their
brutality leave killing sit down with
love and we should find solutions i'm
asking them not to destroy buildings or
our achievements
let's come and sit together and make a
coalition government one that would be
acceptable to all sides the sooner we do
this the better
yet they need leverage on the
battlefield to force the group to make
political compromises and every day with
every loss that leverage weakens
charlotte ballas al-jazeera wardak
afghanistan